تغطي ما يقرب من 450 فدانًا من حديقة الطهاة الأرضية
أو الحديقة ذات المناظر الطبيعية ، وهي
مساحة عامة حديثة مبنية على خطة مهجورة
لإنتاج الفحم والصلب ، وربما تكون
الميزة الأكثر إثارة للدهشة في
حديقة السفن هي تحويل غزة إلى حاوية غاز طبيعي تم
إعادة توجيهها إلى حوض غطس داخلي.
تعد
هذه القصة الكبيرة الأكبر من نوعها في أوروبا
ممكنة بفضل المجلس الوطني الألماني
للسياحة وتأمين السفر Hans Zimmer Corps الذي تم
تشييده في عام 1991 ،
يجذب هذا الملعب الضخم أكثر من
مليون زائر سنويًا في جميع أنحاء
المنتزه ، وهناك العديد من دورات الحبال العالية
والتسلق الخارجي  متنزه حيث
يمكن للزوار تسلق جدران
الهيكل الأصلي وسطح عرض
للاستمتاع بالمناطق المحيطة وآثار
الماضي الصناعي لألمانيا ، وفي
الوسط ستجد مقياس غازات مبجلًا
مليئًا بأكثر من 40 مليون جالون من
غواص مياه الأمطار.
كنت تدير مقياس الغاز في حديقة أتلانتس
منذ عام 2006 ، إذا فعلت ذلك ، فإن تومي فيليجاس
سيقابل أ  تحدث الهندوسي بعد لهجة اللاما ،
لم يكن فرانسيسكو كلارا يحذرنا من
مدى قربنا من الحركة التي عرضت
لسان ماتيو من خلال مزلقة
هيتو الأمريكي الذي ليس إنجليزيًا
لعدادات غزة في حديقة السفن
التي كانت تستخدم لتخزين الغاز
وتنقية الغاز  يمكن استخدامها لتشغيل الآلات ، مما أدى إلى
تراجع في قطاع الصلب والتعدين بالمدينة ، حيث
أغلق المصنع في عام 1980 بعد خمس
سنوات ، أعاد المصممون تأهيل
المساحة ورأوا إمكانات لمركز غطس
اليوم يمكن للغواصين استكشاف مشهد فريد
تحت الماء من صنع الإنسان
مثل الحلقات أو الحلقات السابقة  الهجمات على
كيفية التصويت للتنهد حول أي الأشخاص يجب
عليهم إجراء نوع واحد من اختبارات أوه أليس
نيغا شيت وتنظيم Vox ،
يجعل هذا الحطام من مقياس الغاز وجهة شهيرة
للغواصين من جميع الأعمار
المهمين في التصميم ، لذا فهو أحد المقابض
المضادة للحشرجة في Tulpa Amata  يتدلى من
فوق الحافة وهو يلمع إلى الخياشيم
مسعف GMA يكمن في المجموعة المثالية
مبنى خرجت صوتيًا في
حديقة طهاة غزة فيدر  يجد
حياة جديدة للمهملين والجمال في الحياة
العادية طوال الوقت بينما يقوم بتثقيف
زواره الذين لا حصر لهم حول
التراث الصناعي لألمانيا عندما يتفاعل تقرير إخباري لحدائق أتلانتس ،
آمل أن تتفاعل أعضاء عيد الفصح الكزبرة
المتقشفية مع الدم المرتفع في سيرتهم الذاتية
[  موسيقى]